[Music]
coldplay and bts just dropped the music
video for their collab my universe and
it's definitely out of this world we
always say it's a dream but you know
still can't believe it the whole thing
is set in a distant galaxy called the
spheres where music is forbidden but bts
coldplay and an alien supergroup called
supernova 7 unite via holograms to defy
the ban
[Music]
it's like a mini movie and i'm begging
for the feature film it just felt
amazing my universe will be featured on
coldplay's upcoming album music of the
spheres which is set for an october 15th
release date
[Music]
since its release on friday the track
has already been streamed more than 100
million times just amazing last week
coldplay front man chris martin
performed an acoustic version of the
song on the kelly clarkson show and he
even sang bts's part in korean
that bright infinity inside your eyes
and i
just want to put you
[Music]
the musician also chatted with zane lowe
on apple music one where he opened up
about how the new music came to be it's
a love song yes
that came from
a loving text it had been in my mind for
a while that someone had said
bts
were wondering if we'd do a song for
them or something something like that
and um
the phrase my universe
in this text it was like oh that's a
cool song title the 44 year old rock
star also shared what it was like
working with the korean super group i
love them and we love them and it's been
such a joy so i unabashedly and
unashamedly
really grateful for the song grateful
for the person that inspired the song
and grateful for the people we sing it
with but of course this isn't the first
time bts is singing in english last year
they released dynamite their first
english full song
[Music]
and when e.t caught up with bts to
celebrate the release of the track they
revealed why singing in english was
important to them it was a huge enormous
challenge for all of us we decided to do
it because you know let's try something
new let's challenge something in this
current situation
you know pandemic so
every i think everyone did well quite
well yeah we first listened to the demo
we just loved it and you know let's keep
it this way and we done it cheers to
coldplay and bts for really hitting it
out of the universe with this one
you